did John Stamos just shade Drake Bell have mercy [Music] the 53 year old actor took to Instagram on Saturday to share this sweet pic embracing his grand fathered co-star Josh Peck John captioned the pic I got invited to the wedding and I didn't even want to go hashtag honeymoon backstory Josh tied the knot to longtime girlfriend Paige O'Brien on June 18th surrounded by plenty of famous friends including John and Josh's former Drake & Josh co-star jason nash not invited to the event however was Drake himself and some drama ensued on Twitter and now deleted tweets Drake said quote ties are officially cut between the former friends and when you're not invited to the wedding the message is clear John sure knows how to rub it in yeah [Music]